so we've been talking about the market
revolution in the united states which
was this period in the first half of the
19th century
where the way that americans did
business really changed
and it changed in a number of ways so
the
kinds of work that people did changed
and the people they sold their goods to
changed
in the form of new markets
and even the kinds of commodities that
they were producing
all of these were altered in the first
half of the 19th century
thanks to
a couple of simultaneous
trends
the industrial revolution in which
new technologies were developed to
make production more efficient
and revolutions in transportation and
communication which made it easier to
get goods and people
to far distances more quickly and to
communicate over considerable distances
more quickly
and these really resulted in a
reorganization
of american society
that some historians have actually said
was more revolutionary than the american
revolution
so in the last video we discussed some
of the new technologies which changed
american work in the early 19th century
one of these was the introduction of the
textile mill which was powered by a
water wheel by samuel slater
which helped textile mills become the
chief industry
of new england also helped women start
working outside the home in the lowell
mills started by charles lowell
and also began the system by which
factory owners would hire individuals
rather than family units to work for
wages in their factories
the other major invention that had a
really important impact on american
society was the cotton gin which was a
machine that separated cotton seeds from
the fiber
and it made the production of cotton
considerably more profitable and so with
cotton a profitable crop the american
south really invested in cotton and
investing in cotton as its main cash
crop meant they really entrenched the
system of slavery so even though in the
1780s early 1790s many southern states
were thinking perhaps they'd abolish
slavery because the institution was not
overly profitable as cotton became the
cash crop of the south the institution
of slavery would be entrenched and
continue to grow until the 1860s
so those are some of the new
technologies of production in this video
i want to spend some time talking about
the revolution in communication and
transportation that happened also in
this time period
so just like inventions like the textile
mill or the cotton gin made it easier to
work faster
inventions in transportation and
communication in the early 19th century
also made it possible to transport goods
faster and to transport information
faster so i want to talk about just a
few of these transportation inventions
one of these was the railroad now the
railroad was not invented in the united
states
rather
the united states imported the railroad
technology from england and germany and
this is one of the very first
railroads in the united states i think
it's it's kind of adorable because you
can see how it still is really owing a
debt stylistically to a wagon even looks
like a wagon here on the end
so railroads begin to come into the
united states in the early 1800s
and first they're mostly for cargo or
helping to move
stone things to help build canals which
we'll get to in a second
but soon they're also passenger
rail stations
and the baltimore and ohio railroad or b
bno railroad
which you may know from your monopoly
board
was one of the first passenger
rail lines in the united states
another major transportation revolution
of this time period was shipping on
water
so
in
1807
inventor robert fulton
came up with the steamship
and so a steamship and you can see the
little smokestacks right here uh makes
it much easier to power the ship and one
thing you can do then is go against the
tide of a river so instead of just for
example going down the mississippi river
to the port of new orleans you can also
go back up the mississippi river which
means commerce can go more easily in
both directions
another major innovation of the time
period are canals
and this here is a
map of the erie canal
which was
completed in 1825
and a canal is a
relatively narrow relatively shallow
waterway but it still allows
cargo
barges to move across what otherwise
would be really hard to navigate
territory so you know it's hard to see
here but
there are mountains here right
so now you can take
cargo across mountains across large
stretches of land by ship which is
much faster than trying to do it on foot
or with a wagon
i think it's actually hard for us to
imagine now
but
in the early 19th century and really
for most of time before then
waterways were the highways of the world
it was a lot easier to get from boston
to london across the atlantic by ship
than it would have been to get from
boston to the appalachian mountains
on foot
before the invention of air travel
before the interstate highway system
and really
up until the invention of the railroad
waterways were the easiest way to get
around in the world
and the last communication revolution
that i want to talk about is the
invention of the telegraph
which a portrait painter
turned inventor named samuel
morse
first patented in 1844
and morse invented morse code because
the telegraph worked by sending
pulses down copper wires so it made it
easy to communicate through
coded messages of dots and dashes
so dots and dashes
corresponded with letters
which allowed you to send messages over
extremely long distances
so you could send a message by telegraph
in an instant as opposed to sending a
letter which might take days or even
weeks to get to its destination
so all these revolutions in
transportation and communication kind of
translate into two major transformations
in american business at this time period
one is that the scope
of business that you can do
is much greater because now if you're a
farmer who lives in
say rochester
your
radius of
air
your radius of people you can sell your
produce to before it goes bad
is considerably larger now instead of
just being able to get to where you can
get maybe in a wagons trip of a day you
can send your crops on the erie canal
and suddenly you're dealing with a much
larger market so they're not only
creating a national
web of commerce they're also creating an
international web of commerce because
these canals and steamships go to
international ports which mean that you
can now do business from
the western part of new york with people
who live in london
and the other thing that increases here
is the pace
of business
right so instead of having to
negotiate a business deal through a
series of letters which might take you
many weeks now you can negotiate a
business deal by the telegraph and it's
only going to take you a couple of days
likewise it might have taken you weeks
to send your
logs for example down the mississippi
river now you have them in a steamship
and it takes just a couple of days so
there's an overall expansion in the
number of people who can participate in
markets
the expansion of the distance at which
you can participate in a market and the
pace at which you can do it you can
do business much faster with these
revolutions in transportation and
communication
and in the next video i'll talk more
about how these transformations
in technology and the scope and pace of
american business
affected
the society of the united states in the
early 19th century